in my opinion and I always tell this to
people like obviously I think Atlanta
gets uh the credit for being the strip
club City I personally think Houston's
the best strip club city in the country
right now we definitely you guys got the
Bob thing going on we the place right
now that everybody come to yes every we
is what people look at as the Party City
right now like if you want to go have a
good time great food yeah yeah
definitely I I've learned that we the
the culture is definitely lot of Sak
live there that people don't know live
there that that too I've talked to so
many artists like oh I'm living in
Houston I'm like really I can tell you A
lot of them that yeah tons of them yeah
yeah of course I wouldn't say it on here
but course course there's like like I
was talking to BFB the Pac-Man and he
was like I've been living in Houston I
mean this is on camera so I can talk
about but like a lot of people love
Houston man yeah yeah yeah you get the
good Mexican food not quite as the West
Coast but you get some good Mexican this
is the third you get
this is the third damn time cuz I was on
ad podcast last night and I said Texas
Mexican food is definitely better than
out here n you guys got barbecue though
have you have you ate Mexican food in
Texas so much you got to come with us
then I've gone with give me you give me
a restaurant right now I'm going make
sure I go to before I leave Tex is cool
texme is cool see we ain't even talking
about we not even going to call it txmx
no no no they no they have like me spots
there
like you give me a restaurant here I'mma
take my ass there and I for sure going
to find out you know what it is is I
always say if I rank the best Mexican
food it's San Diego cuz it's right there
the border is right there okay proximity
of course yeah El Paso's got good
Mexican food cuz of course proximity Is
Right wat is right there I was just look
at proximity right the thing about San
Diego is they got all the ill Mexican
food and they got the ill marisco so you
get all the like the seafood [__] the
shrimp cocktail and then La just got the
best taco trucks in the game I got a and
then Arizona then Texas [__]
no y yall not even going to do Texas
like that we ain't letting that happen
you going I'm you need to come to Texas
with us then we going to go that in the
bus I'm supposed to um have you gone hog
hunting out there yet so I did you know
the it's crazy I took me my son and I
just didn't post it cuz you never know
because it is it is a pretty intense uh
video I've seen the videos of the guys
on the helicopters just mowing down pigs
oh yeah no we got in the trenches with
them it wasn't that we in the middle of
the night in the pitch black did you
stab any huh did you nah no you didn't
have to do that I'm going to I'm going
to show you I just never you know I
never post so I got invited to go to
Texas with OT and he said baby we going
to go hog hunted baby and he's like
we're going to be in the back of a truck
with a machine gun just mowing down pigs
and I'm a huge animal lover but I don't
love them enough not to eat them
obviously I wouldn't eat I wouldn't dare
eating no goddamn hog me I'll eat the
swine the swine is divine I mean not
that type of hog we talking about wild
boyss you a you don't want to eat that
see but then I I I I understand why they
want you to kill the Hogs cuz they are
an invasive species in Texas for people
don't know they [__] up crops they kill
uh pets they they're just they're just
not the nicest pigs but they're also the
literal pig that Pumba is in The Lion
King so you know I'm probably going to
end up going and just murdering a bunch
of pumbas in the middle of look at it
like that but if you ever get caught in
the vicinity of one of them you [__] are
they mean are they nice so maybea got
they probably got one of the most
vicious bites you going you know what
maybe that is um the more dangerous way
I'm going to approach this but it'll
make me sleep at night better so I don't
feel like a murderer is I'm going to
just get out of the truck and I'm going
to wait for them to come at me and then
I'm going to kill them oh it's not going
to be that easy and they fast as [__] so
we out there we have to use night vision
to see him from a distance wow I've seen
the videos listen I've seen the Tik toks
there it's crazy that's the next Vlog
we're doing we're going to
Texas oh wow that is a look at that
Pig's teeth
bro do do you um stuff that and hanging
on the wall at home no uhuh you see me
I'm going to take one of them and I'm
going to put it on the podcast
set we're going to do the
Taxidermy he you do know they come in
pack so you it can be a bunch yeah
that's you in trouble if you don't know
what you're doing or you ain't out there
with the right people you [__] what yeah
I mean do is is it a thing you could
inform me do people pay to go hunt him I
don't know you know uh people get paid
to go hunt because so we can make money
yeah because that's why so the people
who go up in the helicopters they
definitely get paid the people who take
people out you know what I'm saying
because it's they so much of a problem
yeah I've heard that they're really bad
for the you know environment and but
they're also like you know little furry
little all right trying to Pi one to
tell me that my friend has a pig yeah
but not that kind of a boy no he's got a
pig like a little pig's dope but boy m
so not a boar yeah boar is not to be
played with that'd be a pretty sick if
you ever did actually you won't even be
able to put a boar down with a handgun
like that not well I so so I had heard
uh I was talking with uh ot's pops and
he was saying that sometimes you got to
shoot it and then you got to slice it
from behind which to me sounds like
something I'm just not willing to do
yeah I ain't got that close to it I'm
good I don't want to ever stab anything
unless I have to yeah definitely if you
got a protect your family if you have to
you're going to stab somebody yeah with
no isation but I'm not going to do it
like just for the [__] cuz it's
Monday I it's Monday let's go [__]
slice some Pig's throats out here um all
right so the new album is uh Stuck In
Motion stuck in MO 18 tracks 18 tracks
it's your first album in a while yeah I
think it's what been five years far as a
real album yeah it's been it's been a
minute you know I threw out songs and
little tapes and stuff but now this is
and even when I threw out tapes it kind
of got lost in the shuffle cuz again we
dealing with life yeah but this is the
first real album that I'm actually you
know crazy thing as much as y'all know
me and I be around y'all I don't really
do interviews yeah you don't do a lot
you see what I'm saying so when I when
you see me talking doing that then it's
it's that time it's time you're on
you're on you're on the campaign yeah
yeah definitely there it is man well
listen go get the album go support it go
buy a a bump boox they're incred always
bump boox come two x's make sure y'all
go get that they're amazing yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh if you break a cord though
you're [__] cuz like so the thing is
they just got to reach out to us a lot
of people do that and once they lose a
cord they be like man my box ain't
working like if you didn't give me the
opportunity I I there was so I you you
had given me like when me and had
interviewed you a while ago I think
Jeezy came up to the station at the same
time when I had my daughter with me yeah
you had your daughter with you you had
given me like a small like one of the
smaller ones right right and um the cord
went out so I tried to buy that cord on
Amazon I I bought like three different
cords and none of them would keep this
thing on yeah and I called when you guys
open the store I was like oh this is
great this isn't too far I called the
[__] store I said hey guys I got this
model uh can I just go up there and buy
a cord and they were like nah we don't
sell just the cord and I was like well
[__] I know [__] you didn't just call me
cuz I you know I I did call you and then
you just sent me a a whole new bump box
that's the easy way too yeah so that's
when I got the big doggy style one and
Doggy Styles my favorite hip-hop album
ever oh yeah well top three you know at
any given day it could be number one so
do style was a classic for sure um but
yeah so go get a bump box they're
incredible and a slap stick yeah yeah
and some headphones and by the way the
headphones sound amazing it's I mean the
ones I have are probably four or five
years old at this point but they sound
[__] great people didn't know so you
know it's crazy people didn't really
realize how dope they were now everybody
trying to get them we going
cuz at the time there was like those
beat studios and yours sounded way
better cuz those were the ones I was I
was using at the radio but then I got
the ones from you and they sounded
[__] way better yeah and you know
once we were out everybody like [__] man
we need to get that and that's like it's
too late but but the in ear is the way
to go that's what everyone's doing and
the thing is with me being in music my
part in the Rob and and everybody over
there is like we always going to make
sure our [__] louder more Bas here more
clear yeah so that's the thing we go for
you know we not trying to we're not
trying to hit a quick lick for sure yeah
yeah so no for sure the India is going
to kill um my glass is coming out with
um Habibi glasses that's going to be
crazy um the movie the cartoon movie
coming me and Mazy still got a movie
unreleased in the whole I just saw you
posted yeah yeah we you guys got a whole
album together yeah we already had one
out we got a second one just sitting up
wait how long ago did you guys put that
out like 2016 W yeah yeah cuz for people
who don't know Mazy has albums out with
artists that you before you even like
cuz I I really the first time I
interviewed Mazi was 2017 and I think he
had the [__] with you he had the [__]
with Gunplay out he's got a bunch of
collab album you know that's that's my
little brother for real for real like
our relationship is it ain't even really
about the music for sure